Max Fisher, Vox.com Foreign Editor: Russia
is invading Europe in 2014.
This is a big deal.
CNN Anchor: "The Russian military now being
directly involved in fighting Ukrainian government
forces."
Samantha Power: "Satellite imagery show Russian
combat units -- combat units southeast of
Donetsk in Eastern Ukraine."
So President Obama, western leaders, everybody
is furious about this.
Obama: "Russia has deliberately and repeatedly
violated the sovereignty and territorial integrity
of Ukraine."
To understand why this all happening in Ukraine,
you have to go actually have to go back to
2012, which is when Russian President Vladimir
Putin ran for re-election.
There were big protests in Moscow, St. Petersburg,
and a couple other places.
He completely panicked, and that's when he
shifted political strategies from economic
growth to anti-western paranoia, conservative
Christian orthodoxy, and a Russian imperial
revival of nationalism.
Then jump ahead to November 2013, that's when
the Ukraine crisis breaks out.
You have protesters in Kiev that want to topple
the pro-Russian government and replace it
with a pro-European government.
Putin sees this as a direct threat, fomented
by the Americans against Russia.
When the government falls, that's when he
invades to annex Crimea.
He gains a huge popularity boost in Russia
over this, it works out for him wonderfully
politically.
And he gets addicted to it.
And that's why shortly after that, he starts
supporting these pro-Russia separatist rebels
in Eastern Ukraine.
The rebels take over a couple of cities, Putin
starts escalating, and in July he hands the
rebels these very sophisticated surface-to-air
missiles which they use to shoot down Malaysian
Airlines flight 17.
CNN anchor: "US officials say pro-Russian
rebels are responsible"
Ukraine is fed up, the west is fed up, Ukrainian
military moves in to re-take these eastern
cities, and actually push out a number of
these rebels.
Putin really panics because he thinks he's
going to lose everything and has bared this
huge cost of economic sanctions for doing
it.
He couldn't afford to build up the crisis
as so crucial for Russia and then just kind
of watch these rebels lose.
So he was pulled into an invasion that clearly
is not going to work out in his long term
strategic interests.
And the thing that makes that so scary is
that if that's the case, that means he has
no strategy, it means he has no actual objective
that he's trying to achieve, and it means
that there's no clear end in sight for this
crisis.